thank you very much good morning after
the distressing images we've seen I'd
like to
Shin what expert institutions like the
engineers Museum in Berlin can actually
do what measures they can take to
address the issue of protecting the
cultural heritage of Iraq and Syria at
home and more specifically what we are
doing at the moment I would like to
touch briefly upon four points actually
integrated object care and presentation
fighting the illicit traffic in cultural
property on a national level bilateral
capacity building programs and finally
finally raising awareness for cultural
property / deck protection agenda let me
start by briefly introducing the
engineers museum located in the Pergamon
Museum on Berlin's museum Island the
engineers museum houses a collection of
about five hundred thousand objects from
ancient Mesopotamian society so it's a
collection of reference for these
ancient Mesopotamian societies we have
signature collections from Iraq and
Syria namely us or Babylon or oak tell
hala abu bakr be returned aim only a few
and it's important to point out that
ninety-five percent of these collections
come from regular archaeological
excavations mostly at the beginning of
the 20th century and they were
transferred to Berlin on the basis of
bilateral division agreements with
respective source countries we have been
a leading research institution with a
focus on object oriented research and in
our mission statement we say that we
consider ourselves a public repository
for the archaeological heritage of Iraq
and Syria of course dealing with this
heritage and protecting it starts in our
storage facilities so what we're doing
of course is something that I would like
to call the integrated object care and
presentation when I say integrated I
mean that these objects are not only
considered by us as archaeological
objects or pieces of art but also as
cultural heritage of Iraq and Syria and
this integrated up
karen presentation includes state of the
art storage preventive conservation
digital documentation especially in the
area of 3d digitization basic research
very important provenance research on
the history of the individual
collections and a multi-perspective
presentation the second area of activity
I would like to comment upon is fighting
the illicit traffic we've just
inaugurated a large national research
project focusing on the illicit traffic
with archaeological objects in Germany
the project is called illicit and in
London I should probably point out that
this is not a mistake not a spelling
mistake but an acronym for a German
title we're undertaking an explorative
study with special attention to
archaeological objects from Iraq and
Syria which means we're looking into
object types turnovers networks
operation modes etc very important is
that this is a transdisciplinary
research design which also relies on non
academic partners especially law
enforcement and customs authorities our
associated partners include the Federal
Foreign Office the federal commissioner
for culture and media the German
Commission for UNESCO and of course I
come with it international observatory
of illicit trafficking the project is
financed by the Federal Ministry for
education and research generously with
1.2 million third area of activity
that's important for us is what we call
bilateral capacity building programs
together with our partners from Iraq
we're about to initiate an Iraqi German
expert dialogue on Iraq's cultural
heritage at archaeological sites and
museums I chasm is supposed to be a
bilateral expert panel for the planning
and coordination of a large-scale
capacity building cooperation program
between Iraq and Germany so we're
talking about an expert panel that is
setting out methodological and
operational
guidelines defining infrastructural
political legal scientific and
operational requirements for a
sustainable exchange and development of
knowledge in Iraq that is important the
project was initiated by the permanent
delegate of Iraq to nesco MP engineer
East museum the partners here include
the German Commission for UNESCO and the
Orient Department of the German
archaeological Institute as well as i
cam financial support comes from the
federal Foreign Office and my final and
last point as a public institution we
know that we have to raise awareness for
the cultural property protection agenda
as a whole and we're doing that on a lot
of different fields and one example of
course is our public support for the
ongoing revision of the German cultural
property protection law from 2007 most
of you will know that the new law is
aiming at better import controls more
effective return mechanisms and strict
due diligence principles related to the
EU directive 60 2014 the new law also
envisions export documentation by the
respective source countries for all
archaeological objects to be imported to
Germany this is very important if it
actually happens it will change things
completely and the German government has
pleaded or actually recommended that the
EU council also deal with this problem
and implements corresponding measures on
the EU level because it is clear that as
long as there is illicit trafficking
with archaeological objects from Iraq
and Syria it will not be able to protect
this cultural heritage effectively in
the future thank you very much
you